- He's an actor
(peaceful orchestral music)
and producer best known for playing
Jesse Pinkman in the Breaking Bad series.
At 19, he drove to LA in
his 1982 Toyota Corolla
with $6,000 in savings and his mother
to follow his Hollywood dream.
He's the only actor to
ever win the Emmy Award
for Outstanding Supporting
Actor in a Drama Series
three times.
He's Aaron Paul, and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(whooshing)
(echoing boom)
(click)
- For longevity, if you want longevity,
(humming)
you got to be picky with
the roles you choose.
And it's all about it
has to be on the page.
You know, if it's not written properly,
then you have nothing.
So if you get a script sent your way,
that they're interested in you,
and it's really solid on the page,
then you have something to work with.
But other than that, then no.
(click)
I had so many ups and
downs, so many struggles,
so much rejection, but to me,
I never saw myself going home.
And to be honest, the first
time I ever asked my parents
for any sort of financial help,
which was so hard for me to ask 'em,
'cause this is my dream,
it's not their dream.
And of course they want to see
their son succeed in their dreams.
But first time I asked
them for any sort of help
was right before booking Breaking Bad.
I was like "Could you
help me with my rent?"
And they paid my rent
three months in a row,
which was so hard for
me to allow them to do.
And it was so hard for
them to do it, you know.
They had nothing.
And then I booked Breaking Bad,
(energetic music)
and you know, the rest is history.
(click)
When I first moved here, they're like
"Listen, all you got to
know is the strong survive,
"and if you're strong
enough, you'll survive."
And so I have always remembered that.
(click)
There's been times where I was like wow,
this is really hard, this is really hard.
I mean, just the ups and
downs, and where I'm like wow.
I'll get like back-to-back jobs,
I'm like my career is
like really taking off!
And then there'll just be a standstill,
and it's just like roll with the punches
and just deal with the rejection.
And it took a minute to understand
that that's such a huge
part of this business.
And now I just don't take it personally.
I just like you know what,
there was someone better for the role,
and there's another job out there.
(click)
There was doing church plays
since I was a little itty baby.
(murmuring)
I was the baby Jesus.
I don't know if I knew then, but I think
around like eight or
nine, when I was doing
kind of like the leading
roles, I was obsessed with it
and kind of just ran with it.
(click)
When I get the script,
I just kind of dissect.
I read it just front to
back, and then I start
really dissecting each scene
and kind of understanding
why he's in this particular situation,
why he's feeling, these sort of things.
But it's all so much on the page.
And so I just, how I dive
into a particular scene,
I just try and live those
moments as if I were Jesse.
I don't try and have certain triggers
or think about some sort of torture
that I personally have
went through in my past.
I just try and really live and breathe
through this particular person's skin.
And with Jesse, it's a constant struggle.
And so it's a little rough at times,
but it's such a blast.
(click)
I always tend to gravitate towards
the more complex side of things,
just complicated characters,
just because for me, it's
just more interesting to play.
(click)
A lot of roles are coming my way
where I'm playing like
the lovable drug addict.
But what I want to do is do
something completely opposite,
just do something that is different
than something I've ever done,
something that's kind of
terrifying and scary to me.
But that's what it's about.
Gravitate towards just such,
(murmuring)
just different kind of roles, ya know.
Like I try to do stuff that's
always kind of terrifying.
Not terrifying as a story,
but it just terrifies
me as an actor to play.
(click)
Embrace every moment, 'cause it flies by.
Just embrace everything.
(humming)
And I've really taken that to heart,
and I have embraced everything.
(click)
- Most of us have recovered
enough to go on, Rod.
(laughing) Who's our next player?!
- [Rod] Well, let's see what
we can do for Aaron Sturtevant!
(joyful jazzy music)
(cheering)
(applause)
Come on down!
Aaron, you're the next
contestant on The Price Is Right!
(laughing)
- Oh! (grunting)
You're the man, Bob!
Oh my, you're my idol!
- [Bob] I have the horrible
feeling I have another one!
(laughing)
(applause)
(cheering)
Here's the next item up for bid.
(jazzy music)
- [Rod] An elegant flat top desk!
(cheering)
(applause)
- (laughing) Aaron, what
do you bid on that?!
- 1200 bucks! (yelling)
- 1200 bucks!
(ding)
(applause)
Michelle.
- 775, Bob.
- [Bob] 775!
(ding)
Charleta.
- 800.
- [Bob] $800.
(ding)
Tracy!
- 850!
- Her bid is 850.
(ding)
Actual retail price, 1,797!
(cheering)
(joyful jazzy music)
Aaron wins!
(dinging)
(applause)
Aaron is the winner.
Let's get him over here!
Right here, Aaron!
Congratulations!
- I'm touching Bob Barker!
(laughing)
Yeah!
(yelling)
- Aaron!
- Yes?
- Aaron, believe it or not,
I have another one of these!
- [Rod] A new car!
(dramatic joyful jazzy music)
(cheering)
(applause)
- Alright, we're going
to play the Dice Game.
Light up the first number in
the price of the car, please!
- [Woman] Come on Aaron!
(ding)
- Here are the dice.
Now, remember there are no
zeroes in the price of the car.
- Okay!
- There are no numbers higher than six.
- Yes!
- Role, and let's hope it's
the second number in the price.
- [Woman] Go Aaron!
- The first number is one.
(cheering)
Now you've rolled a one.
(buzzing)
Is that the second number?
(applause)
(yelling)
No.
Is the second number
higher or lower than one?
- Higher, higher!
- Of course, it has to be.
(ding)
Okay, next number in the price of the car.
Is it six?
(cheering)
(applause)
(buzzing)
No!
Is it higher?
(yelling)
Lower than six!
Roll!
Aaron, we're on a hot streak!
(ding)
Is it three?
(groaning)
(buzzing)
No.
Is it higher or lower than three?
(yelling)
- Higher!
- Higher than three.
(ding)
Alright, roll that last number.
Is it four?!
(groaning)
(buzzing)
No!
Is it higher or lower than four?
(yelling)
- Lower!
- Lower than four.
Let's find out.
(ding)
Does Aaron win the car?
Light up the second number, please.
(ding)
(cheering)
Light up the third number, please.
(applause)
- [Woman] Come on Aaron!
(ding)
- Give us a number higher than three!
(cheering)
Yes!
(applause)
Give us a number lower than four!
(buzzing)
Oh!
(low horn melody)
(groaning)
Aaron, I'm sorry!
- Oh!
(joyful jazzy music)
(laughing)
I get to spin the wheel, right?!
- That's right!
(cheering)
He'll spin the wheel!
(applause)
We'll be back after this!
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video
(peaceful orchestral music)
because Orion Dark Night asked me too.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Aaron Paul's
top 10 rules resonated the most with you.
Leave it below,
I'm going to join the discussion.
Thank you for watching, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(echoing boom)